the deadline thing you can do the dead I
think the dead eye thing was the thing I
thought everybody could do where I just
sort of make one of my eyes go like a
bit lazy we're doing it so it's
effective yeah but so I can do it I
think I've got a slightly laser anyway
and so I just did that and then it does
it just makes me look very dead on
screen and as soon as I and they put all
the other makeup on her stuff and when I
saw that it was like okay I don't have
to worry about playing dead I look
really really dead but they made a dead
Daniel yes they did make a dead me dead
means made before but this was the one
that got put through the wringer like a
lot but Paul down I wanted me on it that
most the time he got very strong idea
around and they're dead Daniel much
excitement because dead Daniels here
[Applause]
it's like he's dead it's like he's dead
no no no you know Willie sit-up not
really
so yeah touch his hand it's so creepy
yeah that's weird
it really is all falling apart at this
point but he's been sent down rivers he
got mauled by a bear like this was all
things we did to him during filming am I
really good look at the look at the
eyebrows it's really horrible I don't
know I don't know what's happening to it
at the end of the press tour so if
anybody you know wants it he will look
worse
oh yeah so much based on that reaction
there's no telling what type of
experience dead Daniel could have yeah
so yeah so actually like leaving here
which I put in by leave never been okay
cool you want him gone
I mean it's white this because he is
sort of staring at me there you go
[Applause]
only only very slightly paler than him
though one shade it's beautiful
[Music]
you